how Steve Jobs influence movies and
movie making we're going to make some
history together today Steve Jobs
visionary technology pioneer where r of
turtlenecks but did you know that Steve
Jobs also had a huge influence on movie
making let's take a look at the role
jobs played in film exhibit a animated
movie back in 1986 George Lucas wasn't
so sure animated movies had a future and
the graphics group of Lucasfilm was in
trouble then Along Came Steve Jobs and
for the tidy sum of five million dollars
he bought the department now known as
Pixar and allowed its employees to
follow their dreams of creating the
first-ever 100% computer animated movie
the result Toy Story Exhibit B movie
trailers the year was nineteen ninety
eight and the first teaser for the
Phantom Menace sought fans lining up at
cinemas hang for a full movie ticket
just to watch the trailer then a couple
of Star Wars lovers and Steve Jobs web
dept saw an online version of the
trailer which had quite a few glitches
they believed they could do it better
using apple's quicktime so in 1999 Apple
hosted a new longer version of the
trailer to watch you just had to install
quicktime on your apple computer at the
time this was the biggest internet
download event in history exhibit speed
movie making one of the beliefs Steve
Jobs always had was that people could
create amazing things if they just had
access to the technology as well as
opening up the world of movie editing to
the masses the inclusion of the video
capabilities on the iPhone 3s met
everyone had in their pockets the power
to shoot their own movie and finally
Exhibit D movie consumption the
introduction of the iTunes movie store
by steve jobs in the mid-2000s offered a
vast array of film content to watch
first fire download and then soon via
streaming somebody should make a movie
out of this so all of that my friends is
exactly how Steve Jobs influence movies
and change moviemaking forever not to
mention getting Michael Fassbender into
a black turtleneck thanks for watching
remember to Like comment and subscribe
to movieclips trailers
you